ryla rodinger and his supporters went to
kenya's supreme court just before the
deadline for challenging the election
results
he submitted dozens of boxes of
documents as evidence along with his
petition it asks the court to nullify
the election's outcome on several
grounds there are forgery of election
documents
there was
interference with the integrity of the
technology
that was used in the elections
there was also a
falsification of results
which were uploaded into
the networks that were operated by the
electoral commission
kenyans voted in elections two weeks ago
ryla rodinga has run for president four
times before leading the opposition
this time he had the backing of his
historical rival outgoing president
uhuru
forward his kenyatta opponent was deputy
president william ruto
last week the electoral commission
declared him the winner with just over
50 percent of the vote
[Music]
ryla's supporters don't believe it
many of them believe he's been rigged
out of election victories before
he's challenged the results of the last
three elections in court supporters of
riley redinger hope that the court
process will favor them as it did five
years ago and rider rolling a challenge
the election results and the supreme
court ruled that there have been serious
irregularities and it ordered a re-run
that time he boycotted the rerun saying
the electoral commission failed to fix
the problems
this time he said he has the evidence to
prove criminality in the electoral
process the corruption cartels are
prepared to compromise electoral systems
bribe election officials
make security systems look other way
or even kill in order to
find their way to power
ryla's petition is one of several
submitted to the court respondents
including the electoral commission and
william ruto have four days to submit
their responses the court has two weeks
to complete its hearing and give a
verdict it could uphold the election
results or order a recount of votes
or a rerun of the polls
malcolm webb al jazeera nairobi kenya